Quisiera hablar sobre tendencias tecnológicas,
que es algo que muchos de Uds. siguen --
y que también nosotros seguimos, por razones relacionadas.
Obviamente, siendo WIRED una revista de tecnología, las tendencias en la tecnología
son cosas acerca de lo cual escribimos y debemos saber.
Pero también forma parte de ser cualquier revista mensual --
uno vive en el futuro. Y tenemos un largo tiempo de entrega.
Debemos planificar los números de la revista con muchos meses de anticipación,
debemos adivinar cual será el apetito del público en 6 meses,
o en 9 meses en adelante. De modo que estamos en el negocio de pronosticar.
Nosotros también, como muchas compañías, creamos un producto
basado en las tendencias de la tecnología.
En este caso, nuestro producto es sobre ideas e información, y, si tenemos suerte,
algo de entretenimiento. Pero el concepto es casi el mismo.
De modo que tenemos que entender
no sólo por qué la tecnología es importante, hacia donde se dirige,
sino también, muy importante, el cuándo -- el tiempo es todo.
Y es interesante, cuando miras las predicciones hechas
durante el pico del boom de los noventa, sobre comercio electrónico
o sobre el tráfico de Internet, o sobre la adopción de banda ancha, o sobre la publicidad en Internet,
todas eran correctas -- sólo erraron en el tiempo.
Casi todas las predicciones se cumplieron, sólo que unos años después.
Pero la diferencia de unos pocos años en las valoraciones del mercado de valores
es obviamente extrema. Y por ese motivo, el timing lo es todo.
Probablemente han visto algo como esto antes.
Esta es la clásica Curva de las Expectativas de Gartner, que nos habla
de la trayectoria de la vida de una tecnología.
Y para divertirnos un poco, hemos colocado unas cuantas tecnologías en el gráfico,
para mostrar si es que estaban subiendo durante el primer pico,
o si se estaban por venir abajo
en el valle de la desilusión,
o volver a trepar en la subida del entendimiento, o -- etcetera.
Esta es una manera de pronosticar la tecnología, hacerse una idea
de hacia donde se dirige la tecnología, y luego anticipar el próximo rebote.
Tendemos a cubrir cada tecnologia que creemos que es suficientemente importante
dos veces. Una vez, queremos ser los primeros en cubrirla.
Queremos ser los primeros, por los geeks que lo van a apreciar,
tratamos de atraparla allí mismo, en el despegue tecnológico.
Por ejemplo en el 1997, pusimos a Linux en la portada de la revista.
Pero luego, regresa. Y las tecnologías suficientemente grandes,
llegarán al gran público, y explotarán.
Y entonces, es hora de hacerlo nuevamente, en este caso, el año pasado.
Y esa es una manera con la cual intentamos temporizar las tendencias tecnológicas.
Me gustaría conversar acerca de una manera de pensar acerca de tendencias tecnológicas,
lo que yo llamo mi gran teoría unificada de predicciones del futuro,
aunque es más cercano a una pequeña teoría unificada de predicciones del futuro.
Se basa en la presuposición, u observación,
de que todas las tecnologías importantes pasan por cuatro fases en su vida --
al menos una de las cuatro fases, a veces las cuatro.
Y en cada una de las fases, se la puede ver como una colisión --
una colisión con algo diferente --
por ejemplo, un precio crítico que cambia la tecnología
y también sus efectos en el mundo. Es un punto de inflexión.
Y estos puntos de inflexión son los que te indican
cual será el próximo capítulo en la vida de esa tecnología,
y quizás te indique como se puede hacer algo al respecto.
El primero es el precio crítico.
La primera fase en el avance de una tecnología
es cuando cae por debajo de un precio crítico.
Y después de caer de ese precio crítico, tenderá,
si tiene éxito, a crecer por encima de una cierta masa crítica, una expansión.
Muchas tecnologías, en ese punto, desplazan a otra tecnología,
y ese es otro punto importante.
Y finalmente, muchas tecnologías se tornan en "commodities"
Sobre el final de sus vidas, se vuelven prácticamente gratis.
Cada uno de esos puntos es una opotunidad de hacer algo al respecto;
es una oportunidad para la tecnología para realizar cambios.
Incluso si te perdiste, por ejemplo, el primer boom de WiFi --
ya sabéis, WiFi alcanzó el precio crítico, alcanzó la masa crítica,
pero aún no ha desplazado a otras, y aún no es gratuita --
aún quedan oportunidades allí.
Quisiera demostrar a lo que me refiero,
contando la historia del DVD,
que es una tecnología que ha pasado por todas las fases.
El DVD, como saben, fue introducido al mercado a mediados de los 1990
y era bastante caro. Pero como pueden ver, para el 1998,
había bajado de los U$S 400, y U$S 400 era una barrera psicológica.
Y allí empezó a despegar. Y pueden ver que las unidades
comenzaron a crecer, se alcanzó un punto de inflexión oculto, y empezó a despegar.
El próximo punto que alcanzó, un año más tarde, fue la masa crítica. En este caso,
el 20% de los hogares es en general un buen indicador de masa crítica.
Y lo interesante aquí
es que otra cosa despegó junto con los DVDs -- los home theater.
De pronto, tienes un DVD en tu casa,
tienes video digital de alta calidad,
tienes un motivo para tener un televisor de pantalla grande,
tienes un motivo para tener sonido Dolby surround 5.1.
Y tal vez tienes motivos para comenzar a conectarlos,
e incorporar también el resto del entretenimiento.
También es interesante notar que Netflix fue fundada en 1999.
Reed Hastings está aquí. Él vio claramente que ese era el momento,
que era un punto de inflexión, que podía hacer algo con eso.
La siguiente fase que se alcanzó fue el desplazamiento.
Como pueden ver, alrededor del 2001, las ventas finalmente sobrepasaron a las de las cintas de video.
Aquí también se puede ver el impacto en el mundo en general.
Netflix tenía razón -- el modelo de Netflix podía basarse en el DVD
de un modo que los negocios de alquiler de video no podían.
Una de las muchas ventajas de los DVDs es su pequeño tamaño,
lo puedes insertar en un buzón de correo, y el envío es barato.
Eso le dio una ventaja; fue una implicación
del despegue de la tecnología que no era obvio para todo el mundo.
Y finalmente, los DVD se están acercando a la fase gratuita.
Hay una compañía llamada Apex, una empresa china de marca blanca,
que ha estado, varias veces en el último año, en el primer lugar
en venta de reproductores de DVDs en EEUU. Su precio de venta en el último año ha sido de U$S 48.
Uds. conocen
la estampida, tal vez apócrifa, en Walmart
sobre el DVD de 30 dólares.
Pero se están volviendo muy, muy baratos,
y miren las consecuencias interesantes. A medida que se vuelven más baratos,
las marcas premium, los Sony y demás, van perdiendo cuota de mercado,
y las marcas sin nombre, los Apexes, van ganando.
Se están volviendo commodities, y eso es lo que sucede
cuando los precios van hacia el cero. Es un mercado difícil.
(risas)
Ahora que ya he presentado esas cuantro maneras de mirar la tecnología,
esas cuatro fases de la vida de una tecnología
me gustaría mirar otras tecnologías que hay allí fuera,
simplemente tecnologías en nuestro radar -- y usaré estos lentes,
estas cuatro, como manera de explicarles
dónde está cada una de ellas en su desarrollo.
No son necesariamente las 10 tecnologías más importantes--
sólo son ejemplos de tecnologías
que están en cada uno de esos estadios.
Pero yo creo que las impliciaciones cuando van alcanzando
esos puntos de corte, esas intersecciones, son interesantes de razonar.
Comencemos con el secuenciamiento de genes.
Como Uds. saben, el secuenciamiento de genes -- en gran medida,
debido a que se basa en computadores -- está cayendo de precio
de una manera similar a la Ley de Moore.
Ahora es posible -- será posible,
y si Craig Ventner realmente viene hoy,
les podrá contar algo sobre eso --
secuenciar el genoma humano por 40 millones de dólares para finales de este año.
Eso en contraposición con los miles de millones que costaba hace unos años.
Ya saben, nuestra capacidad de capturar las herramientas de la creación
se acercan más y más.
Lo interesante es que al mismo tiempo, el número de genes
que vamos descubriendo está creciendo muy rápidamente.
Cada uno de esos genes es un test de diagnóstico potencial.
Llegará un día
en que podrás hacer cientos de miles de tests realizados, a muy bajo costo,
si quieres sabelro. Puedes aprender acerca de tu propio mosaico.
He aquí otra tecnología que está acercándose a un precio crítico.
Esta es una investigación fascinante de la OMS que muestra el efecto
de medicamentos genéricos en los compuestos anti-retrovirales.
En enero del 2000, el precio era de 10.000 dólares, o 27 dólares por día.
Los genéricos llegaron, primero a Brasil y otros lugares
y el efecto en los precios fue dramático.
Hoy cuesta menos de 50 centavos por día.
Y lo interesante es que si miras la elasticidad de los precios,
si miras la correlación entre los dos,
a medida que los anti-retrovirales bajaron, la cantidad de gente que puedes tratar
subió radicalmente. La Fundación Clinton y la OMS
creen que podrán tratar a 3 millones de personas en el mundo para el 2005 --
dos millones en el Africa sub-Sahariana.
Y la caída en el precio de los medicamentos tiene mucho que ver con eso.
Linux es otro buen ejemplo.
Ahora hemos alcanzado la masa crítica.
Estas son tecnologías que estan alcanzando la masa crítica.
Si miras aquí, aquí está Linux en rojo, y ha alcanzado el 20%.
Es interesante que ya había alcanzado un cruce antes,
pero no el cruce que importa.
El cruce que va a ser importante es con el azul.
Pero puedes mirar y ver la dirección en que van esas líneas.
Puedes ver que al 20%, ahora se lo toma en serio.
Ya no es sólo para los tecnófilos.
Esto es, me imagino, lo que a la gente en Redmond
les despierta en la mitad de la noche.
(risas)
Otra tecnología que vemos por todos lados son los automóviles híbridos.
No se si alguien tiene un Prius 2004, pero son fantásticos.
Y si miras las tendencias aquí, alrededor del 2008 --
y yo no creo que este sea un pronóstico loco --
serán un 2% de los autos vendidos.
2% no es 20%, pero en el negocio de los autos,
que se mueve lento, es algo enorme, es un rival.
Con un 2%, comienzas a verlos en las carreteras en todos lados.
Y lo interesante del despegue de los híbridos
es que has introducido los motores eléctricos en la industria automotriz.
Es el primer cambio radical en tecnología automotriz en 100 años.
Y una vez que tienes motores eléctricos, puedes hacer cualqueir cosa:
puedes cambiar la estructura del auto de cualquier modo que se te antoje.
Puedes tener frenos regenerativos, puedes tener conducción electrónica,
puedes tener carrocerías reemplazables
es una pequeña cosa que comienza con un híbrido,
pero puede conducir a una nueva era del automóvil.
VoIP es algo de lo que pueden haber oído algo.
Nuevamente, viene de ningun lado,
es un poco difícil de usar hoy en día.
Hay una compañía creada por los fundadores de Kazaa llamada Skype.
Miren estos números. Lo lanzaron en agosto del año pasado;
ya tienen cerca de 4 millones de usuarios registrados --
eso es masa crítica.
Lo mismo pasa del lado de los carriers.
Estamos viendo como la IP sobrepasa a algunos de los
estándares tradicionales de telecomunicaciones. Es un punto de quiebre --
si Malcom está aquí, perdóname -- y va a cambiar la ecuación económica,
y la velocidad, y los jugadores de la industria;
Será un poco así.
Y por último, gratis. Gratis es realmente interesante.
Gratis es algo que llega con lo digital, porque
los costos de reproducción son esencialmente cero. Viene con IP
porque es un protocolo tan eficiente. Viene con la fibra óptica,
porque hay tanto ancho de banda disponible.
Gratis es, como Uds. saben, el regalo de Silicon Valley al mundo.
Es una fuerza económica. Es una fuerza técnica.
Es una fuerza deflacionista, si no es manejada correctamente.
Es la abundancia, en oposición a la escasez.
Gratis es probablemente la parte más interesante.
Aquí tienes la cantidad de canciones
que se pueden almacenar en un dico duro.
Ya saben, podrían ser también películas
pero básicamente, todas las canciones grabadas en la historia se podrán almacenar
en un disco de 400 dólares en el 2008. Dejará al elemento entero
el elemento físico, de las canciones, fuera de la mesa.
Y Uds. han visto los números.
Me refiero a que la industria discográfica esta implosionando
frente a nuestros ojos, y Hollywood también está preocupado.
Están enfrentándose a una fuerza a la que nunca se habían enfrentado.
Su respuesta es draconianana, y no necesariamente
los va a sacar de la situación en la que se encuentran.
Y por último, un ejemplo final de gratuito --
tal vez el más potente de todos. Ya mencioné la fibra óptica:
su abundancia tiende a volver gratis las cosas.
Este es el precio por minuto de una llamada a la India.
Lo interesante es que en 1990
cuando el precio era de más de 2 dólares por minuto,
India aún tenía un sistema telefónico regulado, y nosotros también.
Era sorprendentemente no-innovador, se movía muy lento
pero había tanta fibra disponible ahí fuera
que no lo podías detener, y miren qué rápido bajó el precio.
Bajó a 7 centavos el minuto, en muchos casos.
y la consecuencia de las llamadas telefónicas baratas, de las llamadas gratis
a la India, es el programador enojado, es el outsourcing.
Es probablemente uno de los movimientos más drásticos de la globalización,
y una de las herramientas económicas más poderosas
que estamos viendo en el mundo hoy.
La fuerza de India, luego China, y cualquier otro país
que puede contactar a nuestros mercados
y trabajar con nuestras compañías -- porque las comunicaciones son gratis --
recién se está comenzando a sentir.
Y yo creo que es probablemente una
de las tendencias tecnológicas que estamos viendo hoy.
Muchas gracias.